Je voudrais vous laisser sur cette pensée.
Sur la gauche il y a l'eau qui arrive à la rive,
prise depuis un satellite de la NASA.
Sur la droite, il y a un corail.
Si vous prenez de la glande mammaire et l'étalez
et enlevez le gras, elle ressemble à ça sur un plat.
Ont-ils le même aspect ? Ont-ils les mêmes modèles ?
Pourquoi est-ce que la nature reproduit ce modèle encore et encore ?
J'aimerais vous suggérer
que nous avons séquencé le génome humain,
nous savons tout sur la séquence du gène,
la langue du gène, l'alphabet du gène,
Mais nous ne savons rien, mais rien,
sur la langue et l'alphabet de la forme.
C'est donc un nouvel horizon merveilleux,
C'est une chose merveilleuse à découvrir pour les jeunes
et les vieux passionnés, dont je fais partie.
Alors allez-y !
(Applaudissements)